in god we trust so steht es auf jeder us
dollar note religion dass es zumindest
in den usa ein wichtiger bestandteil des
öffentlichen lebens
so fehlten auch mein heutiger gast
riesige hallen mit ihren predigten die
lutherische pfarrerin nadja bolze weber
ist in den usa längst ein star
obwohl oder genau weil sie eine sexuelle
reformation der kirche fordert guten
morgen frau wäber herzlich willkommen
frau weber ich habe es gerade eben
gesagt sie sind in den usa ein großer
star ein superstar
das ist ein bisschen übertrieben was
macht sie überhaupt so berühmt hier ist
das nicht so bekannt dass pfarrerinnen
so bekannt sind
nun ich versuche wahrheiten
auszusprechen die sonst ungesagt blieben
und ich versuche ehrlich zu sein was
mich betrifft
wenn ich einem thema nachgehe schaue ich
welche resonanz es bei mir auslöst finde
ich etwas schwieriges über mich heraus
nutze ich das als beispiel
ich spreche nicht als expertin von oben
herab zu den menschen teil ihrer
berühmtheit hat aber sicher auch mit
ihrem äußeren zu tun sie haben viele
tattoos ist das sowas wie ein unique
selling point für sie hat ja sein dass
man da als erstes darauf achtet aber ich
habe vier bücher geschrieben darunter
drei new york times bestseller die in
acht sprachen übersetzt worden sind
so etwas geschieht nicht weil man
tattoos hat die anfängliche
aufmerksamkeit wird man dadurch auf
jeden fall nicht aufrechterhalten
ich möchte gerne über zwei dieser
tattoos sprechen sie haben hier am
handgelenk eines das heißt sinne and
saints können sie darüber erklären was
was es zu bedeuten hat was von ihnen ist
heilige was ist sünderin da steht simon
hughes
bator auf lateinisch es bezieht sich auf
luthers gedanken dass wir alle zugleich
ganz und gar gerechte und zünder sind
gewisse theologien sehen den menschen
als verwirrtes und gänzlich böses wesen
während andere theologische richtungen
den menschen als verkörperung gottes und
als durch und durch gut und geheiligt
ansehen
keine dieser beiden haltungen scheinen
mir zu treffenden beschreibungen des
menschen zu sein zu sagen wir sind immer
und gleichzeitig beides scheint mir
richtiger und letztendlich auch
hoffnungsvoller als die beiden
extrempositionen die uns als die ganze
wahrheit verkauft werden wo sind sie
selber für sich das dass sie eine
sünderin und eine heilige sind ich habe
erlebt dass gott schönes und erlösendes
durch mich erwirkt trotz meiner
schwierigen seiten
ich bin manchmal zynisch und launisch
oder werten
dann bin ich auch noch eine genesene
alkoholikerin
ich habe ecken und kanten und darf doch
teilhaben am schönen in der welt das ist
ein aspekt ich werde nicht alleine über
meine schwächen und meine fehler
definiert sie haben auch noch maria
magdalena tätowiert hat das auch damit
etwas zu tun
maria magdalena habe ich mir während
meiner pfarrer
in ausbildung stechen lassen und mich
daran zu erinnern dass ich nicht trotz
sondern vielmehr gerade wegen meiner
unzulänglichkeiten zur pfarrerin berufen
bin
maria magdalena war die erste zeugin der
wiedergeburt und damit die erste
pfarrerin ohne ihr zeugnis gäbe es das
christentum nicht sie war auserwählt die
geschichte will uns glauben machen sie
wäre eine prostituierte gewesen was
übrigens nicht aus dem text hervor geht
da wurde einiges vermischt sie hatte
aber ihre dämonen schwierigkeiten mit
denen sie kämpfte und von denen sie
durch die begegnung mit christus erlöst
wurde
damit kann ich etwas anfangen sie ist
deshalb für mich eine wichtige figur in
interviews verwenden sie auch eine sehr
direkte sprache immer wieder ich habe
sogar gelesen dass sie zu gott beten er
möge sie doch ein weniger großes
arschloch machen meinen sie das ernst
risses provokation wie muss man das
verstehen
das meine ich zu 100 prozent
das ist meine art glaube glaube wird uns
immer wieder verkauft als die
möglichkeit uns zu läutern oder zu
heiligen als ob wir mit genug beten oder
auch yoga unsere ecken und kanten
abschleifen könnten machen sie auch ja
sehr oft
es scheint bei mir aber nicht wirklich
zu greifen mein großer traum ist es
während einer yogastunde nicht mehr
wütend zu werden bisher leider ohne
erfolg
spiritualität wird uns sehr oft als weg
verkauft unsere ecken und kanten
abzuschleifen rhein zu werden
mit ausreichender übungen würden wir
durch solche praktiken geheiligt ich
glaube aber dass wir uns gerade über die
rauen und gebrochenen seiten unseres
menschseins miteinander und mit gott
verbinden können
es ist nicht das glatte rheine sondern
das raue
ich fühle mich menschen erst wirklich
verbunden wenn sie mir ihre schwierigen
seiten offen legen
diese verbindungen schaffen und so geht
es mir auch mit gott ihm muss ich nicht
meine strahlenden oder annehmbaren
seiten präsentieren
da brauche ich keine spirituelle hilfe
ich brauche sie aber für meine
schwierigen seiten
ich glaube sehr stark an das konzept der
gnade und kann mir eingestehen dass ich
ihre bedarf dass sie sprechen hier etwas
wichtiges an weil jetzt haben ja auch
ein sehr bewegtes leben sie waren ist ja
alles schon gesagt alkoholikerin sie
haben sogar abgetrieben das haben sie
noch nicht so lange öffentlich auch
mitgeteilt sie sind aber eine weibliche
fahrerin für viele christen ist es ein
problem diese kombination welche rolle
spielen für sie kritiker sie spielen
eigentlich keine rolle
die menschen die sich zu einem
christentum hingezogen fühlen indem die
kontrolle von körper sexualität oder
haltungen im zentrum steht und dass die
menschen in eine blechkiste steckt und
vorgibt dies sei das wahre christentum
haben bereits so viele pfarrer für die
gibt es so viele bücher und so viele
redner an konferenzen die brauchen mich
nicht ich bin nicht für sie berufen
worden sondern für die menschen die in
einem solchen christentum keine heimat
finden
viele fühlen sich zu den schönen seiten
der christlichen lehre und praxis
hingezogen
sie sehen darin ein geschenk werden aber
abgestoßen durch seine verpackung im
christentum verwechselt man oft die
verpackung mit dem geschenk inhalt
sind denn insgesamt jetzt aus erfahrung
heraus gesprochen ihre leser der der
bücher die sie schreiben weil soweit ich
weiß wenn sie in christlichen buchläden
nicht verkauft
nein christliche buchläden führen meine
bücher nicht aber man findet sie bei
bands & noble also in normalen
buchhandlungen
mir scheint dass meine leser sich zwar
von christus angezogen fühlen aber
unglücklich sind mit einem beschämenden
und formalistischen christentum
ich bin viel unterwegs und als rednerin
an events erzählen mir die leute immer
wieder dass sie sich der kirche in der
sie aufgewachsen sind nicht mehr
zugehörig fühlen
die geschichten ähneln sich sie haben
mit der kirche gebrochen weil sie nach
der scheidung der mutter von ihrem
gewalttätigen mann von der kommunion
ausgeschlossen wurden oder weil sie als
homosexuelle gezwungen waren zwischen
sexualität und spiritualität zu wählen
ich höre nie dass jemand ausgetreten ist
weil jesus nichts anzubieten hätte mein
publikum hegt die liebe zu jesus lehnt
aber die kirche ab die seinen namen
trennt sie haben anfang des jahres oder
vor einigen monaten für viel wirbel
gesorgt weil sie frauen aufforderten
ihre purity ring also was die keuschheit
bezeugungen einzusenden
und sie wollten das so eine zu einem
kunstwerk machen was was haben sie da
genau um was geht es genau
es gibt in amerika dieser
keuschheitsgebot mit viel gutem willen
bringe ich das mitgefühl auf diese aus
der aids krise heraus zu erklären
aus dem gefühl dass sechs tödlich ist
wollten christliche eltern ihre kinder
bewahren
sie schossen aber weit über das ziel
hinaus indem sie ihren kindern sagten
das ist gottes gebot sei sich vor der
ehe
jeglicher sexualität zu enthalten
insbesondere mädchen bekamen diese käufe
als zeichen ihres gelöbnisses etwas
seltsam wird es wenn dann der vater
seiner tochter blumen schenkt und wie
bei einer verabredung mit ihr tanzen
geht genau an einem kreuz ball da steckt
dann der vater seiner 11 oder 12
jährigen tochter den ring an den finger
wir wissen noch gar nicht worum es geht
eigentlich bevor sie wissen was 6
überhaupt ist was sie wollen und wer sie
eigentlich sind versprechen sie ihrem
gott ihrer kirche und ihrem vater zeus
zu bleiben bis ein anderer mann ihnen
bei der hochzeit wieder einen ring an
den finger steckt genau du schenkst also
deine sexualität erst dem einen dann
einem anderen mann ohne dass sie je dir
gehört ich habe sehr viele junge frauen
getroffen die das ohne zu hinterfragen
mitgemacht hatten was sie stark prägte
sie hatten sich nie als sexuelle wesen
erlebt und waren komplett abgeschnitten
von ihrer lust das hat viele frauen
verliert ich hatte dann diesen traum
dass mehr frauen ihre keuschheit ringe
schickten und ich sie zu der skulptur
einer vagina ein schmelzen würde
entsprechend dem biblischen vers aus
schwertern pflugscharen und aus spiesen
sicheln zu machen etwas was einen
verletzt
um zu funktionieren in etwas heilendes
die skulptur wurde von nancy andersen
gestaltet die unter dem label sweet bird
studio all meinen schmuck macht
die wagen aus kultur habe ich dann auf
der bühne einer feministischen konferenz
der majors konferenz glorias deinem
geschenkt
ich finde das sehr spannend es ist ja
aber trotzdem eigentlich so siehst sie
beschreiben da wie die die sie die
frauen auch gelitten haben unter diesen
ringen aber trotzdem ist es doch so dass
es ziemlich verbreitet ist wir haben
auch im internet diverse bilder und
angebote gefunden von diesem komitee
rings ja das geschieht immer noch ich
kann nur hoffen dass diese jungen
mädchen die man so hintergeht irgendwann
später den weg zu sich zu ihrem körper
und ihre sexualität finden
obwohl die kirche versucht das alles
abzutöten
wie waren denn insgesamt die reaktion
auf diese aktion den ringen lagen
unfassbare briefe bei in denen stand
bitte schmelze in einer hat mir nur
elend gebracht
[Musik]
die frauen berichteten über sexuellen
missbrauch durch männer in ihrer kirche
sie fühlten sich beschmutzt und
beschädigt durch das was andere mit
ihnen gemacht hatten
die briefe waren herzzerreißend es gab
viel kritik die leute waren völlig von
der rolle
die konservativen christen huston die
aktion und sahen darin götzenverehrung
[Gelächter]
aber das stört mich nicht ich arbeite ja
nicht für sie sondern für diese frauen
ich sehe das absolut und ich verstehe
das anliegen man könnte aber trotzdem
sagen für diese leute ist es sehr
wichtig man man kann es respektieren und
das was sie machen könnte man so
verstehen als würden sie sich darüber
lustig machen aber um die frauen aus der
unterdrückung zu holen gehe ich dieses
risiko gerne
mich stört nicht dass die unterdrücker
sich dadurch verhöhnt fühlen
da ist mir die freiheit viel wichtiger
man muss natürlich diese bewegung eben
auch auf dem hintergrund der der
landschaft der religiösen landschaft der
usa sehen es gibt auch viele
fundamentalistische christliche
gruppierungen in europa kennt man das
insgesamt viel weniger einzelne kennt
man eben auch wahre liebe wartet und so
weiter aber es ist hier nicht so
verbreitet ist das stimmt das dass es so
stark in europa sieht es beobachtet
haben
auf meinen reisen in europa sehe ich
nicht die gleichen extreme wie in
amerika amerika ist auch weniger säkular
als europa die historische verbindung
von stadt und kirche ist für amerikaner
sehr fremd wie fühle ich mich stärker
als amerikanerin als an einem ort der
eine staatskirche kennt und beides stark
verwoben ist weil alles privat ist quasi
und man muss mit mit spendengeldern die
kirchen finanziert
ja es ist persönlicher und kommt nicht
so sehr aus der zivilgesellschaft
aber ich habe auch in europa eine
leserschaft die sich offenbar für meine
botschaft interessiert als ich meiner
kirche noch vorstand wandte ich mich in
meinen predigten an mich selbst und
meine gemeinde schätzte es mit zu hören
auch im schreiben meiner bücher lasse
ich mich lenken davon was ich hören muss
es freut mich wenn es anderen hilft wenn
andere negativ darauf reagieren hat es
nichts mit mir zu tun sondern mit
dh sie haben diese gemeine gemeint ist
ja auch haus aus sind es 11 heißt er für
sich als für die anderen gegründet
das stimmt in einer gewissen weise ich
habe sie gegründet aus dem wunsch dass
es so etwas geben sollte
damit ich ihr vorstehen konnte musste
sie aber für die mitglieder da sein wäre
sie reiner selbstzweck hätte ich sie
nicht verlassen
ich ging ja im juli um dem gründer
syndrom entgegenzuwirken
eigentlich begann ich meinen abgang
schon im gründungsjahr vor zehn jahren
zu planen
kommen wir vielleicht noch zu ihrem buch
sie haben kürzlich dieses shameless
geschrieben und da fordern sie eben eine
sexuelle reformation
sie schreiben dass die kirche die
sexualität kontrolliere und sie eine
konkurrenz eben zur zur religion
darstelle da frage ich mich erstmal von
welcher kirche reden sie und inwiefern
konkurrenz ich bin ja durch die
evangelisch lutherische kirche ordiniert
eine relativ liberale glaubensrichtung
in amerika bei der ordination musste ich
zustimmen entweder in einer ehe oder
unverheiratet zölibatär zu leben
darüber habe ich zu meiner schande nicht
viel nachgedacht ich wollte der zeit
verheiratet und es war egal
dann wurde ich geschieden und plötzlich
spielte es eine große rolle
ich war mit einem durch und durch guten
mann verheiratet aber unsere verbindung
hat uns beide nicht erfüllt wir lebten
eine sehr einsame ehe ohne jegliche
intimität und das war für mich schwierig
in meiner neuen beziehung nach der
scheidung fühlte ich mich auf jeder
ebene stark verbunden emotional
körperlich sexuell spirituell
das war großartig und gut für meinen
geist meinen körper mein herz und meine
seele
ich war gesünder lebte aber im
widerspruch zu einer regel die mir meine
kirche auferlegte ich verstand nicht
weshalb es besser für meine gemeinde
sein sollte wenn ich keinen sex hatte
das war widersinnig weil ich so offener
und gefühlvoller was also das hängt
irgendwie zusammen sagen sie also ein
spirituelles wesen kann auch ein
sexuelles wesen sein können sie das
genauer erklären wo jetzt diese
konkurrenzliga sie ansprechen
als ich ein paar wochen mit eric
zusammen musste ich dreieinhalb wochen
auf lesereise für die britische und
deutsche ausgabe meines buches und die
ganze sache quälte mich wir skripten
miteinander und ich fragte ihn der
übrigens nicht christlich ist warum
glaubst du versucht die kirche schon so
lange die sexualität zu kontrollieren
er sagte ohne zu überlegen ich habe
immer gedacht die kirche versteht sechs
als konkurrenz er hatte recht
und mir war sofort klar dass ich damit
das thema für mein nächstes buch hatte
in den folgenden eineinhalb bis zwei
jahren befragte ich meine
gemeindemitglieder zu den botschaften
der kirche in der sie aufgewachsen waren
zum thema sex körper und geschlecht und
dazu wie sich diese botschaften auf sie
ausgewirkt hatten und wie sie als
erwachsene damit umgegangen waren
das buch ist das ergebnis dieser
gespräche war das kein problem für die
gemeinde dass sie sie so intime fragen
jetzt so intime fragen gestellt haben
ich war erschüttert von ihrer
bereitschaft dieses gespräch mit mir zu
führen
als ob sie auf die fragen gewartet
hätten es strömte nur so aus ihnen
heraus plötzlich erkannten sie den
zusammenhang zwischen der botschaft der
kirche und ihrer verletzung
die prämisse des buches ist wenn die
lehre der kirche den menschen schadet
sollten wir die lehre überdenken
ich argumentiere dass wir eine idee eine
doktrin oder eine interpretation eines
bibelverse sni höher gewichten sollten
als den menschen was ist denn so
gefährlich an der sexualität dass sie
von der kirche als also ja quasi so nur
mit handschuhen berührt wird
das hat mit der angst vor frauen zu tun
viele lehren der kirche gründen auf
frauenfeindlichkeit frauen wurden immer
schon als bedrohung männlicher macht
angesehen männliche dominanz in der
gesellschaft bedarf der kontrolle der
körper und sexualität der frauen
das ist keine meinung sondern schlicht
und ergreifend die geschichte der
menschheit
dann hat sexualität auch etwas
metaphysisches sie ist geheimnis um
wurden sechs wie auch in der religion
versuchen wir unsere existenzielle
einsamkeit zu überwinden
unsere tiefste angst beruht auf unsere
existenziellen einsamkeit
deshalb streben wir nach verschmelzung
in der religion suchen wir die einheit
mit gott im sex suchen wir die
verbundenheit zu einer anderen person
und mit beidem lässt sich diese
existenzielle einsamkeit überwinden
das ist eine der gemeinsamkeiten zu
lassen kommen
sie sind ja selber in einer
fundamentalistischen evangelikalen
kirche in den usa aufgewachsen haben
sich davon distanziert sie haben sogar
gesagt sie hätten jesus gehasst war das
wirklich so um es klar zu sagen ich habe
jesus nie gefasst das ist das einzige
was immer noch mehr gehört die kirche
die vorschriften ich wuchs in einer
kirche auf in der frauen in gegenwart
von männern nicht laut beten durch
deswegen ihre geschichte umso spezieller
eigentlich ja irgendwie schon ich hatte
nie eine frau in einer spirituellen oder
religiösen führungsrolle gesehen bissig
27 war
nein überhaupt nicht
das ist ein enorm wichtiger teil meiner
geschichte ausgerechnet ich wurde die
pfarrerin oder die pastorale stimme von
menschen die in einem sehr konservativen
christlichen glauben aufgewachsen war
und an bestimmten teilen festhalten
wollen aus selbstschutz aber viel davon
zurückweisen müssen
ich möchte darauf jetzt noch etwas
genauer eingehen sie haben eine sehr
berührende geschichte wie sie überhaupt
fahren geworden sind wenn ich mich
richtig erinnere haben sie eine
begräbnis rede gehalten für einen freund
da sich so zitiert hat und da haben sie
dieses quasi erweckung gefühl gehabt
können sie das erzählen
ich bin unter meinen freunden auf die
einzige gläubige und so auch damals ich
war noch nicht am seminar was dein job
kommentieren und in der genesung ein
freund von mir auch ein comedian und mit
mir im zwölf schritte programm der
anonymen alkoholiker hatte den kampf mit
seiner psychischen krankheit verloren
und sich so zitiert seine beerdigung
fand in einem comedy club in der
innenstadt von denver statt
im vollbesetzten comedy works meine
freunde haben mich angeschaut und gesagt
du kannst dass du musst die trauerrede
übernehmen und ich habe eingewilligt
aber das war sicher weil ich die einzige
gläubige waren
sie haben noch gebetet in dieser zeit wo
sie so quasi diesen schlimmen absturz
hatten wo sie vier jahre alt
tatsächlich hatte ich ein paar jahre
zuvor zurück zur kirche gefunden
während der trauerrede blickte ich in
die menge mit all den komödianten
transvestiten abstinenten alkoholikern
und akademikern und sah die haben alle
keinen seelsorger aber pasta und mein
nächster gedanke war oh nein wie ich
sollte das war mein erweckung moment ich
wollte nie die pfarrerin der kirche
sein sondern die seelsorgerin für meine
leute sie haben eben dann diese kirche
auch gegründet ich habe es schon gesagt
house of horses and saints und deswegen
nennt man sie eben auch der pastor der
ausgestoßenen wie kam es zu diesem
großen zuwachs bis heute eine große ist
in den ersten paar jahren ist sie nicht
so schnell gewachsen wie ich wollte
es war anfangs sehr frustrierend dann
predigte ich an diesem gesamtstädtischen
ostergottesdienst in red rocks dem sehr
bekannten natürlichen amphitheater
außerhalb denn was vor 10.000 menschen
und ich hatte diese kirche mit gerade
mal 40 leuten der aufmacher der denver
post der zeitung meiner stadt
beschäftigte sich am osterwochenende mit
der frage warum wohl gerade diese frau
den gottesdienst in red rocks leitet
damit verdoppelte sich meine gemeinde
quasi über nacht
man hat mich wahrgenommen und je mehr
leute davon erfahren haben desto größer
ist die geworden ich möchte zum schluss
noch mehr die frage erlauben frau bolz
weber weshalb glauben sie eigentlich
warum ich meinen glauben habe mein
freund frank schaefer hatte als sohn des
bekannten evangelikaler francis schäfer
eine schwierige kindheit mit der kirche
und blieb trotzdem christ als ihn jemand
damit konfrontiert dass er ja immer noch
teil des christlichen glaubens sei sagte
er etwas für das ich ihn immer hassen
werde weil ich das gerne selbst gesagt
hätte wenn es mein größter wunsch im
leben wäre
ds zu sein würde ich mir nicht anders zu
helfen als gott zu bitten nicht dazu zu
machen und so geht es mir auch ich kann
nicht anders
eine andere freundin von mir rätsel hält
evans sagt bei der geschichte von jesus
gehe ich das risiko ein falsch zu liegen
die geschichte ist für mich so
bestechend dass sie mich nicht in ruhe
lässt
doch und noch bedeutet sie mir neues
anderes und schönes sie ist eine linse
durch die ich mich selbst und andere in
der welt sehe ich kann er nicht
entkommen selbst wenn ich wollte
ganz herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
verbunden und jetzt entführen wir sie in
den süden indiens dort steht eine der
größten religiösen stätte des kontinents
geweihtes sie der gelebten chivas
mienack sie einen schönen sonntag und
bis bald
[Musik]